manager of the Boston Red Sox is Alex
Cora
and he is here on the Rich Eisen show
how are you skipper
hey race don't call me skipper I don't
like that by the way
oh this kipper part I like I don't get
used to it honestly but uh besides that
I'm doing well man you know perfect they
offer us okay tough weekend in Baltimore
with a doubleheader on Saturday coming
from Toronto with the turf and obviously
last weekend clean four games against
the Yankees so I will deserve off days
and up there and take trying to take
advantage of it okay so what is other
than my introduction what what is
working for you
now you know what it's a credit for the
players they and know it sounds cliche
and managers always said this and they
really enjoy playing the game like this
weekend it was hard for me to keep
Andrew Pennington me of the lineup or
sandy loan and then you know how it is
you know doubleheader on Saturday they
game on Sunday somebody has to sit you
know we have to take care of them but
they do enjoy playing the game there's
something really special going in the
clubhouse they care about each other and
um you know we give them the information
they digest information they go out and
they play and honestly when the game is
over
you know we win or lose you know they
turn the page and they get ready for
well obviously it's been more winning
than losing what information exactly are
you providing a lot of information from
our analytic Department it is very
important of what we're trying to do but
also there's a lot of stuff that if you
pay attention to the game the game will
will tell you what's going on and and
there they do pay attention our coaching
staff it's one that they in looking at
everything and tendencies or or whatever
whatever the game gives you they trying
to
you know to listen to the game or to and
and and and whatever they see they give
it to the players run Reineke who
managed the Brewers for a while he's
been outstanding as a bench coach and
the rest of them they've been great you
know and without them no no way we're in
this position so I do feel that coaching
staff have been amazing so who's your
influence Alex you spent 14 years in the
majors
who's your managerial influence that you
maybe have coursing through your
managerial veins that you you bring to
bear every day with the Red Sox well
honestly I do feel that the third-base
coach for the Pirates that Joey Cora guy
my brother yep he he's my biggest
influence i I do feel that uh you know
he should be a big-league manager but
you know he hasn't got that opportunity
yet he's been interviewed a few times
and with no no luck but he's been huge
for us for me I mean he he calls me he
texts me he pays attention to what's
going on with us I know he has a job
over there with the Pirates but he
really cares about his little brother
which is great and also you know my
favorite my favorite player was Roberto
Alomar not Joey
you know I think as you know Robbie was
a complete player but also a very smart
player and that comes from his dad and
to Sandy Alomar senior and I play for
Sandy in winter ball in 2000 2001 and
and the way he explained the game the
way he managing him he really stuck with
me and uh he's one of my mentors Alex
Cora manager of the 50 games over 500
Red Sox here on the Rich Eisen show how
good is Mookie Betts Alex he physically
he can do a lot of things that others
can't I think there's two players I I
think physically athletic wise they're
so good they're so gifted that they put
their their bodies in positions to do
damage at the batter's box they can run
and they can play good defense if Mookie
and Francisco Lindor I think both of
them they're very flexible very strong
individuals and they take advantage of
their
athletic ability and on a daily basis
this guy you know Mookie he comes in
with a smile to to the ballpark he
really enjoys the game but at the same
time is very gifted and uh you know he's
taking his game to another level
and he was one of those guys that I look
at last year and when I got the the job
in November I was like if this guy is
better we gonna be a better team and
he's been that much better and we're
very proud of him and we're very happy
that he's leaning out for us well when
you took the gig JD Martinez was a free
agent at the time what I mean
what words of wisdom do you say to
somebody who's is locked in as he is man
I hate to 2:37 in the big leagues that's
my career I mean for somebody who hit
that in the major leagues obviously you
know what it takes to stay mentally with
it in a way and locked in and and
dealing with personalities and dealing
with that's why you're called a manager
and not a coach you know but he went 80
and we met with him in in December
during the winter meetings in Orlando
Scott Boras and his group and JD was
there and and the way he talked about
the game
he is very passionate about it that's
all he cares you know obviously you know
he has a family and everything but he
really cares about the game and is very
very I'm gonna say he he's planned on a
daily basis
he's almost perfect and you know when he
wakes up is watching video he goes to
the to the batting cage and on a daily
basis he's trying to get better and he
has a plan for everybody and one thing
about JD is not about the pitchers
friends you know this guy's 499 and has
a great split it's about what he can do
with his swing against that guy and he
looks for certain pitches in certain
areas and and this season it's been very
special you know it seems like he
doesn't miss a pitch when when whenever
he attacks
it's been amazing another thing that he
does you know he's not afraid to
communicate with his players you know he
is his game plan is his game plan but at
the same time he's sharing information
which is very important for us he's
becoming he is the leader of his team
you know I know it's funny that I say
that because a lot of guys been together
for a while here and he's been with us
whatever it is you know I'm red and I
don't know how many games 120 games you
said we play and he's the leader he is
great you know and he that he has a
passion for the game and I think it's a
perfect fit for the for our city you
know we're very passionate about sports
as you know and he's the same way Alex
Cora Red Sox manager here on the Rich
Eisen show I have my my compadre here
who's in on-air producer and my on air
if you will compadre it was a big Red
Sox fan and wants to ask you a question
Alex I decided to give him some real
estate right here you know in the same
way that you probably delegate as well
yeah you know I hope that this show is
50 games over 500 as well this question
go for it Chris yeah Alex a lot of
people could say well you got two MVP
candidates and Mookie Betts and JD
Martinez but who is the team MVP the
team MVP that's a tough one that's a
tough one I do feel that both of them
are deserving you know you know Mookie
he accepted the leader leadoff role and
he's being great he's getting on base
for for JD and the rest of the guys JD
has changed other things you know lined
up wise I don't know man that's probably
the toughest question I've got in the
whole season so I'm not gonna pick a guy
I'm very happy with both of them has you
know has there ever been like Co MVPs in
the in the history of the game I don't
know we can do that one yeah I know by
the way I was gonna give him a follow-up
question Alex but he wasn't gonna ask
you which is your of your children is
your favorite as well yeah yeah exactly
you know
you know what I mean yeah but you know
what it is it's one of those that you
know those two guys they feed of each
other you know they're there the
relationships in spring training they
click and you see them in in batting
practice and people you know this is
something we we have to deal on a daily
basis they suck in batting practice like
they complain that they lose their swing
I don't have it you know I'm broken over
and I can hit and then all sudden they
get to hit tonight and they hit the
bottle goal part you know I know it's
kind of like a joke that goes around you
know with us you know like they crying
and complain about everything and then
7:05 comes and they also then they get
their swings back and they start
breaking but us you you have to be part
of this you know when to listen to those
two guys talking about how how they
struggle and then I'm the 237 hitter I'm
like just stupid you know don't don't
even talk about it you know so but but
if they come out of the cage Alex and
say man I'm feeling it tonight you got
to be concerned at this point you're
gonna say Brock Holt just to throw us
all off and I know this sound is you
know who a guy that very quietly has
helped us you know in a way that he has
benefit us as far as the pitching staff
you know like using him as a reliever as
a starter or even all that Bryon Johnson
man very quietly he's been huge for us
because with injuries we spot starts and
all that BJ has been outstanding for us
well what do you say to a couple of
minutes with Alex Cora Red Sox manager
what do you say to fans who were
concerned about David Price and his
video game habits Alex um like David
David's been playing video games for
four years you know last year was FIFA
and now he's fortnight his violin is
like like I have
we got about 25 guys mm-hmm I think like
18 of them they play for tonight so yeah
man I mean I like it I don't know what
it's all about whatever but I don't sing
I read um unit you don't play with them
no man I don't I don't I was uh you know
born Nintendo kind of thing you know
back and pay yeah but not anymore
it's so complicated now it is much you
know get online and all this and all
that you don't know who you're playing
against you know some kid that is 14
might be kicking your butt you know all
right so last one for you what's your
plan for Chris Sale moving on for the
rest of the season with hims is locked
in as he is and getting them ready for a
postseason that's clearly you know first
pitch of the game was 90 and they put a
good swing on it and he kind of like
realized hey I'm back in the big leagues
and also 94 97 98 but we're gonna take
care of him you know his next start is
Sunday against Tampa I think the next
one is a week from Friday I think so
we're gonna take advantage of her
schedule we got a lot of off days coming
up and yeah and this is something we've
been doing the whole season taking care
of the guy it's been very disciplined as
far as like you know getting rest and
just understanding that we're never
gonna you know throw him out there for
130 pitches and and he's been good
yesterday to be honest with you I was
very tempted to send him back in six
inning so I had to be disciplined
because I know how important this guy is
for us their breath of August September
and hopefully not oh okay well and you
just be careful if somebody sends a
throwback jersey from the bronx new york
with a return address don't open that
yeah I'll make just I'm just trying to
help out since I started the wrong way
with this interview Alex I wanted to end
on a positive note well you are two men
85 and 35 that is a none too shabby
thanks for joining I look forward to
chat with you
the line you will thank you very much
man come on you got it that's Alex Cora
Red Sox manager through the roof through
the first 120 games the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience